اسمحوا لي أن أسألك عن 2030 لأن المملكة
العربية السعودية تريد استضافة هذه البطولة ،
فأخبرني عن هذا العرض المحتمل
وما تتعلمه من
تجربتك هنا ليس لدينا عرض
الآن حتى عام 2030 ، ما يستحق التركيز عليه هو
المزايدة  بالنسبة لبطولة آسيا 2026
للسيدات ، ونحن
ننافس على كأس آسيا 2027 ، بطولة الرجال
ونقدم أيضًا عطاءات أو
فزنا بعرض استضافة دورة الألعاب الآسيوية 2034 ،
لذا فإن هذا هو تركيزنا الكامل الآن على
كيفية الاستعداد  كيف
تجهز الملاعب البنية التحتية لاستضافة
هذين الحدثين ما تعرفه عن ليونيل
ميسي يعني أنك شاهدت أداءه
على أرض الملعب
أم قبل يومين فقط
دفع السعودي لميسي مبلغًا كبيرًا في الوقت الحالي
ليكون وجه المملكة.  السياحة الكثير
من الحديث لذلك أنه سيحقق
فوزًا من تلك المباراة الأولى مهما
حدث سواء كنت الأرجنتين واحدًا أم
لا.  le
وأنت تعلم
أنني سعيد حقًا
لأن كل الجهود التي بذلناها في
كل التضحيات التي بذلها اللاعبون في
العامين الماضيين ، كل
الانتقادات التي جاءت بشأن كرة القدم السعودية
وجميع هذه الانتقادات قد آتت أكلها
بالأمس وعرضت.
أداء من الطراز العالمي حقًا ، فأنت
تتجاهل حقيقة أنني أسألك عن
ميسي وهو وجه الكنيسة السعودية ، فأنا
لست وزيراً للسياحة ، لذا لا أعرف
ما هي الصفقة ولكنك تعلم أن وجود
السعودية  وجه السياحة يسكن
آسف ميسي كوجه للسياحة هو
شيء إيجابي أعتقد أنه
ذهب إلى السعودية عدة مرات التقيت
به أيضًا في السعودية
أم تعلمون أننا سعوديون نرحب
بالعالم لذا تعال وشاهد السبت  ودعونا
نتحدث عما حدث على أرض الملعب
قبل أن نتحدث نوعا ما عن نوع
القصة الأوسع لكرة القدم السعودية
والرياضة
أم ياسر الشاروني أم ظهرك الأيسر
سيخضع لعملية جراحية
بعد اصطدامه بحارس المرمى
أمس كيف حاله إنه بخير أه
يستردا  لقد نقلوه إلى المستشفى
لديه كسر في عظام الوجه
وعليهم إجراء عملية جراحية عليه ، لذا فهو
بخير كان مستيقظًا ، لقد كان كما تعلم ، لقد
ذهبنا لنكون بخير ، سيكون على ما
يرام تحت قيادة
كريستيانو رونالدو جريئًا  عرض
قدمه نادٍ في السعودية أه العام الماضي لعرض
كريستيانو رونالدو عقدًا لمدة عامين
كما أفهمها 350 مليون
دولار أو شيء من هذا القبيل ليأتي
ويلعب في الدوري السعودي اعتبارًا من
الليلة الماضية رونالدو ليس لديه ناد.
هل سيلعب في السعودية الموسم المقبل
، لا أعلم أن هذه إجابة مباشرة ،
لقد قرأت نفس الشيء الذي قرأته
في الأخبار وأنت تعلم أننا نرى الكثير
من الأشياء عن المملكة العربية السعودية مذكورة
في الأخبار خاصة عندما  هناك
أموال طائلة حولها ، لكنني لا أعرف
أي شيء عن ماهية
خططه المستقبلية ، هل ترغب في رؤيته
يلعب في السعودية الموسم المقبل ، فلماذا لا
تعرف أن لدينا دوريًا قويًا لدينا في
كل فريق لدينا سبعة لاعبين أجانب
ولاعب واحد على مقاعد البدلاء أ
ونأمل أن نتطلع إلى زيادة
لعب فرقنا في المستوى الأعلى في آسيا
وكرة القدم قوية في السعودية ، فلماذا
لا